well a historic vaccination effort is
due to get underway in the united states
with the arrival of millions of doses of
the kobit 19 vaccine
healthcare workers and nursing home
residents are expected to be among the
first to be given the
biotech pfizer vaccine but with the
number of coronavirus deaths in the u.s
approaching some three hundred thousand
it comes too late for many
this is the closest tammy binviet can
safely get to her husband
his is another life hit hard by the
pandemic
he lies motionless unable to breathe on
his own
looking through a window it's nothing
you really want to
you want to do in life it's like through
a window
it's hard over the past two weeks the
u.s
has repeatedly exceeded 2 000 covet
related deaths per day
surpassing earlier pandemic tolls we had
our surge back in may
we were tired we were exhausted and we
thought
wow i don't know how this could really
get much worse and
fast forward to now to this week and the
surge that we thought we were having
then
was really nothing compared to what
we're experiencing now
but a massive logistical effort is
underway that will hopefully save lives
and ease the strain on frontline workers
this weekend the first shipments of the
biontech pfizer vaccine
left the manufacturing facility in the
state of michigan this precious cargo
is expected to reach hundreds of key
sites across the country by monday
two major package delivery services ups
and fedex are part of the ground and air
operations
i was pretty excited they just came up
and said
hey you're going to be one of the few
people unloading
the vaccines for us and you know
that's pretty monumental for us so i was
pretty excited
happy to be helping out it feels like
i can finally do something about these
problems instead of just
staying at home it feels great states
are responsible for the distribution
once supplies arrive
frontline workers and millions of the
most vulnerable
are supposed to get the first doses
you